Follow along as I knit one side
of my baby cardigan using a knit radar.
Shape your knitting
by following along the lines.
My gauge is 28 stitches to 4 inches, and
I'm using the appropriate stitch scale.
On the mylar, the drawing is aligned
to the left at the zero
mark of the stitch scale.
To get started, the instruction
is cast on 30 stitches.
The numbers and the tick marks
on the scale represent
the needles on the needle bed.
We'll cast on needles,
right 1 to right 30,
and then I'll continue knitting without
any shaping until I get
to the arm hole shaping.
At this point, I'm reading that I need
to bind off, decrease,
or short row three stitches.
Notice that the line is between
the three and four marks on the scale.
Now, this is not an exact science,
so I'll use my judgment and choose to bind
off three stitches and make notes as I go.
Because I'm going to be duplicating this
shaping while knitting the other cardigan
front, I'll note my shaping
right on the mylar as I knit.
After knitting two rows,
the curved arm hole line is indicating
that I need to bind off,
short row or decrease two more stitches.
The tick mark is indicating
right needle number five.
Knitting two more rows,
I'll decrease one stitch,
right needle number six.
Knitting two more rows, decrease one
stitch, right needle number seven.
Now you can use whatever shaping methods
you'd like decreasing
bind off or short rows.
This is just giving
you the numbers to use.
We've decreased a total of eight stitches.
Following the straight section
of that arm hole opening,
I'll continue to knit to row 57
until I see this neckline shaping.
Now remember to document
your shaping as you work.
This time I'm going to decrease
one stitch on the right side.
I'll knit two rows, decrease two stitches,
knit two rows,
decrease or short row five stitches,
knit two rows, decrease two,
knit two rows, and decrease two.
I'm choosing to do
my shaping every other row.
You can choose to do your shaping
in other intervals if you'd like.
Just follow the lines so you get
the shaping that you drew on your mylar.
As my neck opening shaping is complete,
there will be stitches on needle
right nine through right 19.
Knit over these 10 stitches
for the shoulders and then bind
off or scrap off on row 68.
This completes one side of my cardigan.
Now to knit the other side of the
cardigan, we'll reverse the shaping.
We'll cast on left 1 through left 30.
Instead of shaping the arm hole
on the left, we're going to shape the arm
hole on the right, following
the lines and the needle numbers.
Then we'll shape the neck line on the
opposite edge of the arm hole shaping.
If this is confusing for you,
draw a left and right side on your mylar,
but remember to duplicate the shaping
instructions so both sides match.
Keeping track of the stitch counts for our
cardigan fronts was
pretty straightforward.
If we were knitting for an adult,
even at one-half scale, the sleeve
probably really won't fit on the mylar.
So we'll just draw half of the sleeve
and half of the sweater back.
As we're knitting,
we'll still follow the lines,
but we'll mirror the shaping
on both sides of the needle bed.
For example, on this sleeve, I'll cast on
40 stitches, needles right 20 and left 20.
The shaping is mirrored
on each side of zero.